hey guys welcome back so last week I
posted a video of the famous tremolo
piece recuerdo Stella Alhambra and so
many of you reached out asking to see if
I would do a video talking about how I
play tremolo so here we are this video
will be in two parts if you are
guitarist who can't play tremolo but who
wants to learn this video is for you and
if you're a more advanced guitar player
but you want to learn how to improve
your tremolo technique next week there
will be a part two just for you so stay
tuned
[Music]
so tremolo on the guitar is like a magic
trick it creates the illusion that there
are two instruments playing at the same
time and the way it works is that
basically the thumb plays its own part
like this are simple arpeggiation and
then that's gonna keep on going but then
we're gonna add the fingers rapidly
plugging in between each thumb stroke
like this
[Music]
and it creates the most beautiful
haunting murmuring melody in the
background
[Music]
so to break that down further between
every thumb stroke we have to fit in
these three fingers in this order ring
middle index so tremolo is when we play
thumb ring middle index thumb ring
middle index on repeat now in classical
guitar or lingo we give the fingers
special names this is P I M and a so
Pema Pema whatever you want to call it
but for the rest of the video I'll be
referring to the fingers by those terms
okay so to learn this technique let's
start by putting all of our fingers in
our right hand except the pinky on the
first string that's the high E string
and make sure when you do this that your
thumb actually goes to the left of the
fingers so it's not inside the hand
hidden it's to the left of the fingers
from your point of view also the wrist
shouldn't be bent in like this sometimes
guitarists like to rest their palm on
the bridge or the wood this is no good
we want to keep the wrist relatively
straight some light natural bend is is
okay so all four fingers on the first
string thumb to the left straight wrist
and now we can start P a M I P
am i that's the basic tremolo technique
okay now once you practice this a bit we
can get ready for our first exercise
it's all about planting the fingers
early on the string so after you play P
the thumb the ring finger is going to
land instantly down on the string which
will stop it early and then when we play
the ring finger that middle finger M is
gonna land early then the middle finger
plays and their index lands early so all
the fingers land early which stops the
strings and makes it sound staccato
staccato simply means short in Italian
so here we go playing staccato tremolo
at 60 BPM and while you do this
try to keep your hands still we don't
want to play with the hands we don't
want to play with the arm keep the hand
nice and still
[Music]
and next we can alternate that staccato
exercise with a legato exercise legato
being the opposite of staccato if
staccato means short legato means
there's no gap between the notes they
are connected like so that's legato so
now we can go back and forth between the
two
once staccato once legato ready go
keep the hands still remember
[Music]
okay the next exercise is all about
learning to control the amount of force
that each finger exerts on the string
and the way we're going to do that is by
practicing accenting one finger at a
time so let's turn a metronome on at 80
bpm and we'll start by accenting P the
thumb ready and this turns out to be
pretty easy because the thumb is
naturally louder than the fingers but
next let's go to the a finger so we have
P a
hey am i next we'll do em em try to be
with the metronome
okay let's move to the index finger hi
[Music]
and lastly we're gonna go for a
completely even tremolo
[Music]
this is surprisingly difficult one
finger
inevitably wants to pop out so spend
some good time here and see if you can
make them really all sound the same okay
so now that your tremolo is working
let's go to the next level we want to
start letting the thumbs skip around
between different strings while the
fingers stay on the first string doing
tremolo this is what creates the
illusion of two instruments playing at
the same time so what we're going to do
is we'll start with all four fingers in
the first string and then one by one the
thumb will jump to the second string
third string fourth all the way to the
sixth string E and then back up for this
let's turn our metronome Jean to 110 bpm
ready
[Music]
remembering to keep your thumb to the
left
flat wrists
[Music]
okay now let's just have some fun with
this if you just hold down a basic chord
like a minor the left hand just leave
those fingers there and we're just going
to do basically the exercise we just did
but your thumb can skip around at random
it sounds like this
[Music]
instantly beautiful and if you want to
even go to the next level we can add a
chord progression to left hand let's try
a minor D minor E major
we'll finish back on a minor here we go
[Music]
okay last thing for the day let's learn
a little Spanish tune called Mel Agana
the whole thing is going to be played
with the thumb and it sounds like this
[Music]
and that's just going to repeat play
this until you can do it perfectly every
single time because next we're gonna add
tremolo between each thumb stroke
[Music]
and then you can go faster
[Music]
now go spend 10 minutes a day working on
these three exercises just like we did
today with the metronome and in a week
or so you'll already be able to start
incorporating this magical technique
into your playing and remember if you're
a more advanced player and want to go
deeper part two is next week we'll be
talking all about more advanced tremolo
techniques but for now thank you for
watching please subscribe if you haven't
already also you can consider supporting
my patreon if you want to help me make
more videos in the future
see you next time
[Music]
you